bonsoir nous sommes le 24 octobre
heureux de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle édition du 7 8 l'aktu le
journal de la rédaction sans plus
attendre voici les principaux titres
plus d'un produits de cosmétique sur 10
vendus actuellement dans le monde a été
produit au sein de la cosmetic valley
qui couvre notamment l'île de france
à versailles les professionnels ont
échangé aujourd'hui autour des
évolutions du secteur et c'est une
première le thème olfaction et
perspectives dans le cadre de la semaine
bleue la ville de la verrière vient de
proposer aux seniors une pièce de
théâtre les seniors au volant
derrière l'humour un message prudent
c'est pourquoi pas inciter certains à
reprendre quelques cours de conduite
jean michel fourgous maire ump
d'elancourt poursuit sa campagne contre
la réforme des rythmes scolaires après
la pétition ils appellent au boycott il
s'en expliquera ce soir il est l invité
du journal l image du jour c'est la
présentation à vélizy 2 ce traceur
chimiques encore assez peu présent en
france l'entreprise auchan a décidé de
le mettre en place afin de sécuriser sa
bijouterie
le principe est simple en cas
d'intrusion un brumisateur inoffensive
se déclenche et imprègne les individus
d'un liquide invisibles à l'oeil nu mais
comportant un code unique un code qui
permet ensuite grâce à une lampe uv
d'identifier à l'auteur et le lieu du
délit
le système est importée d'angleterre il
a déjà fait ses preuves et les services
de police et de gendarmerie devrait
bientôt tous être équipés d'un lecteur
dédié on écoute le directeur français de
la société qui a développé ce procédé
smart water c'est au micro de yolaine
torres le côté révolutionnaire c'est la
traçabilité et résistante dans le temps
c'est à dire qu'on peut marquer quelque
chose
mais qui n'aura pas une résistance
aujourd'hui smart water à une garantie
de marquage de cinq ans en extérieur sur
des objets sur les la peau on va être
sûr du 6 à 8 semaines puisqu'il ya une
régénération de la peau qui va se faire
naturel donc on est à peu près six à
huit semaines sur les capulet un cheveux
poils sourcils
ça va être jusqu'à six mois sur les
vêtements c'est durée de vie des
vêtements voilà c'est le côté
révolutionnaire et dans la traçabilité à
long terme mais avec une précision
ça ne s'est pas uniquement une couleur
qui va permettre la traçabilité
ce sont les codes uniques aussi donc le
code unique va définir vraiment le lieu
où est implanté le système alors il n'y
a aucun problème pour la santé c'est une
innocuité total c'est incolore inodore
et tous les toutous ski à l'intérieur du
produit on est à plus de 95% d'eau et
vous avez des terres rares à l'intérieur
qui sont des désorganisant fait des
métaux qui n'ont aucun principe actif et
puis l'objectif c'est quand même pour
nos clients de rassurer les leur
personnel déjà dans un premier temps
puisque c'est eux qui subissent mais
aussi la clientèle vous voyez ici la
situation vous avez des caisses qui sont
côté de la bijouterie le jour d'un
braquage vous avez les clients qui sont
à deux mètres du braquage à domec du
braquage d'une petite vallée qui fédère
plusieurs d'entre elles organisées
aujourd'hui avec la chambre de commerce
le congrès olfaction et perspectives
utilisez les odeurs dans le domaine de
la santé du marketing de l'environnement
et c'est possible c'est une piste de
développement comme nous l'expliquent
clair qu'en billets et jonathan vilma
les métiers liés aux odeurs ne se limite
pas à la parfumerie
c'est le message que souhaitez faire
passer les organisateurs du congrès
olfaction et perspectives qui se tenait
ce jeudi à la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie c'est aussi surtout de
parler des nouveaux champs d'application
de l'olfaction passe comme on l'a dit
c'est un sens qui était pas mal oublié
jusqu'à aujourd'hui alors qu'en fait
c'est un sens qui va nous permettre
finalement de pouvoir
ouvrir de nouveaux métiers une grande
ouverture en tout cas pour nos jeunes
aussi non seulement dans les métiers
classiques de la parfumerie la
cosmétique ou dans l'alimentaire mais
aussi on l'a vu dans le domaine médical
on oubliera dans le domaine de
l'environnement
parmi les avancées présentées la
détection de maladies par les odeurs ou
encore le lien entre émotion et odeurs
appliquée aux biens de consommation sont
veut positionner a produit comme étant
relaxant une crème y a trente comme
étant relaxante
on pourrait aussi proposer un parfum qui
aille dans ce sens là émotionnellement
pour renforcer et suggéré d'autant plus
ce pouvoir par exemple relaxant de la
crème c'est un peu ça l'idée
donc finalement pour nous en tant que
fabricant de parfums et d'arômes sait
sélectionner nos produits en fonction de
certains positionnements émotionnel
finaux des biens de consommation et des
produits de consommation les yvelines
représente un territoire clé de ce
secteur 500 entreprises de cosmétiques y
sont implantées ainsi que l'école isipca
créée en 1970 par jean paul guerlain
lui-même la région ile de france fait
également partie de la cosmetic valley
avec les régions normandie et centre
c'est d'abord un impact d'attractivité
c'est dans le monde n'y a rien de mieux
donc c'est un peu une silicon valley
dans lesquels entrée en fait un
mouvement qui associe à la fois la
recherche la formation les pme la
cosmetic valley représente 18 milliards
de chiffre d'affaires et prévoit 1500
création d'emplois d'ici 2015 les
salariés divine information jeunesse
structure qui conseille agi pour
l'emploi le logement la santé sont
inquiets quant à leur avenir suite à
différentes démission l association se
retrouve sans représentant légal à
compter du 1er novembre prochain
il interpelle donc leur représentant
olivier maniscalco patrick jacques de
dixmude le bureau yvelines information
jeunesse en danger c'est le message que
ces salariés souhaitaient faire passer
en manifestant ce matin dans les rues de
versailles
même si le financement du bureau reste
assurée par les collectivités y yj se
heurte à un problème de taille à compter
du 1er novembre les salariés n'auront
plus de direction et plus de direction
signifie qu en tant qu'association ils
n'auront légalement plus le droit
d'exercer leur mission en tant que
salarié en fait on a eu aucune
information aucun retour
sur sur la suite sur le devenir des
grecs yj on a lancé aussi une pétition
justement pour qu'on soit soutenue par
les partenaires par les usagers par les
amis de l'information jeunesse en
général et des grecs ige en particulier
plus on aura de signataires qui on aura
un poids la pétition lancée par yves une
information jeunesse a récolté plus de
cent cinquante signataires selon
laurence cousin la ddcs des yvelines a
promis de se pencher d'un peu plus près
sur le cas des sept salariés du bureau
mais évoque un vide juridique sur ce
dossier y y j espère être reçue par le
conseil général
un de leurs partenaires financiers pour
rappel le bureau assure une information
jaloux du département concernant
l'orientation l'emploi ou le logement
nous en parlions hier les sages femmes
de l'hôpital mignot même si elle assure
le service sont en grève pour obtenir
une meilleure reconnaissance de leur
profession aujourd'hui olivier
maniscalco et aller à la rencontre d'une
professionnels qui exercent en libéral
elle aussi est mobilisé l'image patrick
jacques de dixmude charlotte gauthier et
sages femmes libérales à saint germain
en laye comme ses confrères de l'hôpital
du chesnay versailles elle participe au
mouvement de grève lancé le 16 octobre
et réclame plus de considération pour sa
profession
aujourd'hui aussi qualifié qu'un
gynécologue ou un obstétricien pour
accompagner une femme durant sa
grossesse elle constate néanmoins que
ses patientes ne se dirige pas en
premier lieu vers les sages femmes
une tendance qui traduit notamment un
manque d'information
n'est pas très connue en fait des
patients c'est pas très naturel pour la
plupart des gens de dire que sa chambre
la pouvoir sur une grossesse va pouvoir
faire un suivi gynécologique de
prévention et
si on est inscrit comme praticien le
premier recours auprès des
administrations
il y aura obligatoirement derrière une
campagne d'information de la population
pour sébastien et julie qui viennent
aujourd'hui se renseigner auprès de la
sage femme pour l'arrivée de leur
premier enfant
c'est le médecin traitant qui a joué le
rôle d'intermédiaire comme ils n'ont pas
encore annoncé la bonne nouvelle à leurs
proches qu'ils préfèrent garder
l'anonymat
nous venons d'apprendre ma grossesse
nous sommes allés voir le médecin pour
pour la prise de sang et nous a dit il
nous a expliqué que nous pouvons très
bien nous fâcher pas une sage-femme
salissage femmes sont tout à fait
capables d'assurer les suivis de
grossesse ont si bien qu'ils avaient
nicolas manzi tri siens yahia vient pas
de raison pour nous n'envisageons pas
cette possibilité
préférez une sage femme peut être aussi
un choix économique pour l'instant les
consultations sont moins chers que chez
les spécialistes
de plus elles apportent leur aide
physiologique aux patientes pour les
techniques d'accouchement très
traumatisant pour le corps de la femme
des traumatismes qui après la naissance
de bébés peuvent très vite engendré des
frais de rééducation important pour la
mère et pour la sécurité sociale
la semaine bleue se poursuit cette
semaine dédiée aux personnes âgées par
mes mains parmi les manifestations
piloté par le conseil général des
yvelines un spectacle éducatif sur les
dangers de la route les personnes âgées
au volant c'était à la verrière yolaine
torres patrick jacques de dixmude ont
assisté à la représentation
ça fait 90
retour quelques années en arrière pour
ses seniors à la verrière ils révisent
quelques règles de bonne conduite au
volant à travers un spectacle interactif
saut si vous conduisez depuis longtemps
voilà donc puisque nous sommes tous les
deux des conducteurs seniors nous allons
vérifier notre vus ensemble avec
public qui porte des lunettes ici alors
avant des personnes qui pourront
participer
la prévention routière un sujet parfois
difficiles à aborder avec les personnes
âgées
le fait de ne plus pouvoir conduire
représente souvent pour elle une perte
d'autonomie supplémentaires ils ont
parfois du mal à comprendre que malgré
l'autonomie physique qu'ils peuvent
avoir à conduire encore leur véhicule
cela peut représenter un danger pour eux
mêmes mais également pour les autres
donc l'idée c'est vraiment de les
sensibiliser aux dangers de la route ce
qu'ils pourraient rencontrer mais au
danger que même pourrait représenter
certains ont re découvert quelques
règles du code de la route
c'est vrai que j'ai appris des choses
que j'ai sûrement oublié ou et que je
joue que je ne connais que je ne
connaissais pas tout simplement des
choses ont changé depuis 44 ans de
permis de conduire d'autres en revanche
insistent ils sont âgés certes mais le
perthois pour autant leur savoir-faire
dans l'ensemble ça fait ça fait quand
même 40 ans que j'ai mon permis je n'ai
jamais eu de problème c'est vrai que
c'est
c'est important
ils ont je pense que dans l'ensemble les
retraités reste quand même dans le coup
malgré quelques lacunes dans l'ensemble
je pense que on arrive à suivre le code
de la route quand même un peu après quoi
ce spectacle était organisé dans le
cadre de la semaine bleue
elle se termine ce dimanche je reçois
présents le maire d'elancourt l'ump
ancien député de la 11e circonscription
jean michel fourgous bonsoir vous avions
sur ce plateau vous êtes contre la mise
en place des nouveaux rythmes scolaires
comme plusieurs maires d'ailleurs toutes
tendances politiques confondues mais
vous n'hésitez pas à faire savoir avec
une pétition mais aussi maintenant un
appel au boycott
pourquoi une si farouche résistance sur
la mise en place des nouveaux rythmes
scolaires mais écoutez moi je lutte
depuis très longtemps
contre l'échec scolaire je le fais pour
beaucoup de communes
bon ils encourent est plutôt un modèle
de réussite scolaire d'ailleurs ou avec
un modèle très innovant une nouvelle
pédagogie bon donc voilà les maires ils
sont confrontés à à 40 % d'échec
scolaire à l'entrée en sixième
disons de difficultés on va dire à
l'entrée en sixième c'est ça qu'il faut
traiter et nos administrés il nous
interroge là dessus bon alors la réponse
la réponse à ces problèmes d'échec
scolaire ou de difficultés s'est
modernisé la pédagogie comme on le fait
l'encours et puis également améliorer la
formation des profs c'est les deux dans
mon meilleur pour améliorer ça c'est ça
le problème des mers salle prennent des
parts en salle et le prennent de la
france le problème des lieux de famille
avec moi ce que je voulais des bacs à 20
ans tout d'abord personne est d'accord
il n'y a pas d'unanimité qui se dégage
est en plus monsieur peillon bon
je crois prof de philosophie bon très
bien c'est super et seul mais bon pour
moderniser le modèle scolaire et gérer
une entreprise de plus d'un million de
personnes oui on aurait aimé avoir
quelqu'un qui a une vision d'abord
peut-être de gestion parce que quand on
balance un truc comme ça on sait même
pas on n'a même pas regardé comment ça
coûtait et qui paye
moi je vais m'amuser comme ça sur le
tableau sur votre
mais on être entreprises comme ça vous
balancer un truc mais après je me dis
que ça coûte 5 fois plus donc déjà
premièrement on dirait monsieur peillon
monsieur peillon vous faites une étude
d'impact financière commence à coûter
l'encours moi je les fais pour lui s'il
n'a pas fait ça me coûte 1 million
d'euros environ cinq à huit points
d'impôts bon j'ai vu 4 ap
ils sont partis vent debout là monsieur
je vais forme il découvre lui aussi que
ça coûte un million et demi d'euros
je crois que c'était dit sur le plateau
d'ailleurs idem fois ci il est mince et
alors à paris première ville de france
qui ne juge pas ump pour l'instant bon
il avait prévu 10 millions il en soit 54
millions erreur de 500%
vous croyez franchement que moi que je
suis quand même chargé de protéger le le
problème de chaîne et celle encore toi
vous croyez est ce que le problème
financier est ce que c'est aussi un
problème de fond sur le rythme scolaire
est ce que ces rythmes vous considérez
que c'est la mise en place de ces
rythmes ce n'est pas efficace ça ne sert
à rien que c'est pas bon pour les
enfants c'est pas bon pour
l'apprentissage puisque vous vous dites
que la commune d'hallencourt est très à
la pointe sur ces questions
d'apprentissage on pourra effectivement
parlé avec le développement des tableaux
numériques ou encore des tablettes pour
vous ça rentre pas dans l'apprentissage
un meilleur apprentissage que de changer
sinon une démo je suis étonné tous les
ministres sont venus voir de la
recherche et de l'éducation nationale
sont venus l encours plus des
responsables de même de pays étrangers
kiki qui travaillent sur le modèle
scolaire monsieur peillon n'est toujours
pas venue bon mais qui regarde ce qui se
passe elle en cours ou nous il nous fait
revenir en arrière avec ça avec sa
réforme donc il n'est pas question qu'on
aime dépenser autant d'argent
le pouvoir d'achat des français en ce
moment c'est tabou c'est les français
sont au bord de la rupture de
l'acceptation de la légitimité de
l'impôt
attention allez demander à toutes les
communes de france d'augmenter de 5 à
10% leurs impôts ça ça coûte environ 2
milliards la réforme il a oublié il a
découvert monsieur peillon ministre il a
découvert que ça allait coûter 2
milliards je rappelle que la france est
déjà en rouge
elle est sous tutelle de bruxelles vous
avez rajouté 2 milliards de nouvelles
dépenses publiques alors vous êtes déjà
le pays qui a le plus grand nombre de
niveaux de dépenses publiques dans le
monde
mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire surtout
pour détériorer un peu plus le modèle
scolaire parce que les rythmes scolaires
détériore un peu plus la sérénité des
enfants l'harmonie avec la famille sam
est un bazar pas beaucoup je rappelle
que à paris et je regarde les autres
exemples les deux tiers des directeurs
d'école ils sont pas ump
bon ça on n'en sait rien j'ai passé un
pharmacie font pas ils n'ont pas de
courir deux tiers de ces politiques
les deux tiers des directeurs d'école
demande la suspension immédiate de la
réforme c'est je crois que c'est quel
sens sur six ans vous avez lancé
exécution aussi plus que vingt mille
signatures maintenant vous appeler au
boycott quelles conséquences pour la
commune que de boycotter que de refuser
de mettre en place la réforme des
rythmes scolaires est ce qui aura des
conséquences on entend déjà le recteur
de l'académie
l'inspecteur d'académie dans l'est dans
les yvelines expliqué que les communes
qui voudront pas le faire en 2014 malgré
ce qui est prévu dans les textes
eh bien on fera pour eux on mettra en
place les horaires et on leur imposera
des horaires non je vous dire que les
appels au boycott je me souviens de mon
collègue mais un de trappes qui avait
fait un appel au boycott à la au service
minimum qui avait été voté en plus
c'était une loi le savez si les lits
qu'il la respecterait pas bon je vous
rappelle que là il ne s'agit pas du noir
c'est pas une loi la réforme des rythmes
scolaires
si c'était une nouvelle serait ce n'est
pas une préconisation c'est vraiment
notre maison commune de le mettre en
place si c'était une nouvelle serait
anticonstitutionnel puisque vous n'avez
pas le droit de voter une loi qui
entraîne automatiquement mécaniquement
une augmentation des impôts ce qui est
le cas donc c'est un modeste décret
ministériel qu'est ce que pèse un décret
ministériel devant la noble energy aux
communes dit heureusement devant la
limoger n'y a pas de courant un décret
ministériel jeudi devant la libre
gestion d'une commune par les élus c'est
un principe constitutionnel qu'est ce
que pèse ce ce modeste
donc des criminels d'autant plus qu'en
face on apprend que monsieur peillon est
sur le départ que il souhaite lui-même
son départ et j'ai été en contact avec
115 tonnes
je vous le donne en mille n'a pas dire
mais il le dit directement à tous ses
amis qui souhaitent partir ceci dit même
si martel la réforme est toujours là
mais monsieur hollande dit qu'il
souhaite le départ de monsieur pire bon
alors cela dit dans les couloirs
certains enfin ça nous rien vous savez
bonbons donc voilà à quoi ça sert
d'aller fragiliser un peu plus le
pouvoir d'achat nommé animé de mes
administrés qui souffrent qu'ils font un
rejet actuellement de la politique
fiscale des socialistes c'est le rejet
total je n'ai jamais vu ça de ma vie
donc vous en faites pas question des
municipales il n'est pas question que
j'aille ajouter un million de nouveaux
impôts pour une pour une réforme qui est
un échec
c'est un échec dans toutes les villes
qui le font pourquoi voulez vous que
j'aille imposer ça alors que ma ville
est plutôt un modèle vous le savez il ya
des gens qui viennent habiter l'encours
mme les agences immobilières me lisent
ils viennent à fribourg pour le modèle
scolaire un bon pourquoi où les objets y
mettre un mâle non mais mon modèle qui
est plutôt une réussite pour une mesure
qui de toute façon sera pas appliquée
jusqu'au bout il n'y aura pas de son
ministre est en train de partir du
rapace j'adore j'adore mais j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour le recteur qui
était un homme très qu'est ce que vous
essayez notre inspecteur aussi
d'académie mais mais de toute façon eu
bien sûr ils ont fait pression là et
fait pression jusqu'à ce que bien
jusqu'à ce que le ministre parle bon
voilà qu'avec des échanges est ce que
vous avez concrètement discuter avec le
recteur et oui mais c'est un plus
quelqu'un de très doux très cordiale et
développe le jeu que j'aime beaucoup
dehors de ça mais mais mais écouter de
toute façon cette réforme allait
infinançable vous n'allez pas trouver 2
milliards en ce moment le pays en dépôt
de bilan monsieur landais en plus d'être
en train d'accélérer les deux gravement
les difficultés spatiaux et vu les
résultats du chemin chez qu'une calamité
c'est bien de dix milles supplémentaires
en fin de semaine mais ils viennent
avec le bug informatique elle est
internée économie les gens sont en train
de partir les entreprises sont en temps
de partir les entre les grosses
entreprises n'en voient plus leurs
cadres de haut niveau en france parce
qu'avec la poste de 15% music hall est
footballeur on est devant une rame
économique à mon avis qu'est-ce que vous
voulez que j'aille exposer mes élans
courtois et non et notamment mes enfants
mes enfants je suis là pour protéger
leur réussite scolaire et pitt - matane
de sécurité d'aller à les embaucher au
moins 200 zanni metter quatre fois 45
minutes dans la semaine et et qui vont
et qui sont moins compétents que mes
profs parce que les profs bon et il
s'est quand même ils ont quand même une
compétence une formation et d'expérience
l'avons recruté il ya plus tôt ou tard
il apparaître les parents non seulement
les anges arrivé et on apprend que tous
ces gens là vont imposer le projet
pédagogique aux profs mais qu'est ce que
c'est que le projet pédagogique ce sont
les profs ils sont formés pour ça donc
moi je leur fais confiance
donc il n'est pas question que je change
quelque chose ou alors monsieur peillon
vient me voir à elancourt et il me
prouve que d'abord ça ne coûte rien ou
alors qu'il apporte le chèque avec et en
même temps il me prouve surtout que ça
améliore les résultats scolaires des
enfants il encore toi ça je veux le voir
quand stéphane labrie voir s il manque
cette étude d'impact nous sommes allés
rencontrer quelques élans courtois leur
demander leur avis sur cette question du
boycott êtes vous pour ou contre
boycotter cette réforme des rythmes
scolaires
je pense que si le maire lance une
pétition c'est que il considère que
c'était très compliqué à mettre en place
est ce que ça coûte trop cher ouais
c'est un choix c'est un choix
démocratique donc pourquoi pas quand on
n'est pas d'accord on n'est pas d'accord
si c'est pour le bien de tout le monde à
qui s'oppose vraiment je sais pas c'est
son rôle en tout cas qui demande la vie
aux concitoyens je pense que c'est une
bonne idée après qui s'oppose lui qui
donne vraiment un avis tranché je suis
pas sûr que ça soit forcément taureaules
en tout cas qui demande la dit aux
citoyens ça c'est bien il faut bien
qu'il y en ait qui s'ils ont des avis
différents s'ils peuvent s'exprimer
pourquoi pas le faire et encore plus de
la part d'un maire sauf que c'est
peut-être là c'est assez finalement
courageux de se lancer et de donner son
avis sur la question
je pense que il faut préparer ce type de
réforme aujourd'hui à passer de
préparation en particulier par rapport
aux gardes qui se font à côté garderie
ou ou autres types de l'assistance on
voit que les les enseignants et même les
airs d'un vote à gauche sont pas graves
de fournir les cours qui sont attendus
ou les activités donc je pense
qu'aujourd'hui est passé de préparation
pour mettre en place ce type de réforme
passe à cette préparation finalement les
gens sont d'accord cette réforme des
rythmes scolaires fait pas l'unanimité
mais si on avait déjà pu le constater
avec les sondages d'opinion ont tourné
dans le micro trottoir demandé aussi la
vie des citoyens vous le faites avec
cette pétition parce qu'on peut imaginer
aussi une autre forme de consultation
sur votre commune
j'ai écouté j'ai fait 3 rue bourgend une
chance dont moi j'ajoute j'ai fait trois
réunions importantes une avec les
parents une avec les profs et une avec
les animateurs toute personne choisir
les jours le linge il jouit ouais j'ai
vu voilà il ya veille avait il n'y avait
pas d'adhésion alors ensuite j'ai
regardé ce qui se passait dans les
communes je rappelle qu'on est que huit
communes sur 240 pour une commune avec
des avec des écoles qui ont qui ont
choisi un département rural et 8 sur 248
fric peut ajouter aussi pour le coup
comme une commune de droite vélizy
et la communauté de choses et des
yvelines
attention attention là on nous dit que
cette réforme soit disant ça va mais
c'est les injustices et c'est un grand
thème qui utilisent régulièrement
associés pour se faire élire mais à
chaque fois ils augmentent les
injustices et inégalités mais c'est pas
là et là c'est un bel exemple vous aurez
des communes très riches vont vous aurez
des cours de violon des cours
d'équitation
ddd cours de bisous conférence des
français l'anglais aux états unis et
vous aurez des villes pauvres qui font
la pâte à modeler ou de la garderie et
donc ça franchement augmenter ces écarts
il en est hors de question je vous dise
est cette réforme allait infinançable
elle coûte 2 milliards c'est impossible
aujourd'hui elle est injuste elle est
inefficace et en plus elle est
dangereuse parce que vous êtes en train
d'engager des jeunes animateurs qui se
met en concurrence avec des profs ont
beaucoup plus d'expérience et ça fout un
bordel et du coup les enfants sont moins
encadré qu'auparavant donc donc pour
toutes ces raisons je pense et parce
qu'en plus ce n'est pas une loi
et pour cette raison il ya une plage du
sillon et vos boycotterait on ne la
mettrait pas en place là sauf si vilaine
sauf si monsieur peillon
fait une étude d'impact sérieuses au
niveau financier et qu'on voit pas une
erreur de 500% sur la ville de paris et
le bordel que sami dans la ville de
paris aura l'occasion d'en reparler
les enfants en cours d'aidé matérielle
puisqu'on imagine sa crainte m2 un thème
de campagne entre les différentes
tendances politiques d'ici à mars merci
jean michel fourgous d'être venu sur ce
plateau maire d'elancourt opposés à
cette réforme pour terminer ce journal
direction paris une cérémonie a lieu
tous les jours à 18h30 en toute
discrétion c'est le ravivage de la
flamme du soldat inconnu sous l'arc de
triomphe
élus anciens combattants sont présents
il y avait des yvelinois hier de
guyancourt sincères les coller et
fontenay le fleury anthony rech
si les associations yvelinoise d'anciens
combattants peine à trouver des portes
drapeaux la relève forme les rangs pour
le ravivage de la flamme du soldat
inconnu
les passionnés des guerres mondiales à
20 ans le coeur tu mesure l'importance
de la cérémonie franchement
personnellement grand frisson
parce que c'est c'est quelque chose
qu'on fera qu'une fois dans la vie donc
c'est vraiment pas du tout négligeable
et non c'est vraiment un honneur d'être
ici
pendant 25 ans philippe a servi la
france dans la marine
mais il est porte drapeau depuis
seulement une journée il n'a pas hésité
une seconde pour soulever l'étendard
tricolore
grand moment d'émotion un grand moment
d'émotion parce que lorsqu'on a servi la
france pendant 25 ans on ne peut pas
dire non lorsqu'il faut qu'elle veut
remplacer un camarade est représentée
d'ancien combattant des idées à quelques
mois du centenaire de la première guerre
mondiale qui a fait 10 millions de morts
plus aucun témoin du conflit est encore
vivant pour ces anciens combattants de
l'algérie ou du conflit au liban
devoir de mémoire doit perdurer mais
c'est indispensable car n'oubliez pas
que une nation qui oublie son histoire
s'expose à l'art vivant derrière les
drapeaux tricolores 70 guyancourt toit
était notamment présent dans le cortège
le ravivage de la flamme du soldat
inconnu a lieu tous les jours à 18h30
depuis 1923
c'est donc la fin de ce journal je vous
retrouve demain pour une nouvelle
édition très bonne soirée sur tv fils
oui